be very clear about what you're doing
you are reporting your fellow Americans
and neighbors to men with guns and you
think that men with guns coming in and
hauling them away is a justifiable
response so in Texas right people tend
to be pretty responsible you see it's
important to people wearing masks
servers are wearing masks people are out
there living their lives I went to
Michigan and it is okay let me let me be
as clear as I can with this and I want
to know if any if any of you out there
feel this way I've never had this kind
of a visceral reaction on an issue
politically I used to get really upset
when people would say uh Barack Obama's
present I don't recognize my country I
used to try and be the voice of reason
and say listen still the same country I
disagree with nearly all of Barack
Obama's policies but we have checks and
balances and it's not that bad I've
never been a doomsday guy that's why
they change my mind book went initially
pitched too conservative publishers was
turned down because I said it too happy
so that's always Rev yw+ I went to
Michigan and for the first time I said
this state has lost its mind and when
I'm in Mission I don't even recognize my
country well I do not recognize my
country people are terrified people are
walking around with mass but here's the
thing they're not terrified in the way
that you would expect so there's a few
places that are allowed to be open and
there was a place that's a brewer remain
nameless but you know this beauty has a
nice outside patio okay so it's open now
so Michigan is open for business
which you know you desperately need
because Detroit so we win the anchor and
they won't let you go in through the
they won't let you go in through the
main door lobby way whatever you guys
call it you have to go outside of the
patio and there's basically you know
somebody's like a Maitre D' but
basically it's a it's an armed guard
though she's not armed it's just a
hipster in a crocheted mask so she's
hidden there and she goes you have to
wear a mask enhancing it so you have to
pump the hand sanitizer and put on the
mask okay so have to put on a masters
yeah until you sit down because the
germs can't get me when I'm seated yeah
and I see everyone go and I see everyone
going out they're sitting down they go
and they put on their masks and then
they go and they sit down they ordered
they order there because you have to
drink and then when they go up to the
bar they put on their masks and I see
people most of them wearing their masks
below their nose yeah I see them taking
a dirty old mask from their backpack
okay putting it on and I go you don't
want hole in a second let's think of
this for a moment if this were like
Ebola in Liberia where Samaritan's Purse
won and despite you wanting to vilify
and have 50% death rate yeah these
people will be acting very differently
they would all be holed up in their
house yeah instead I am looking at a
population of people who are clearly not
afraid of the virus they're afraid of
their government when you put okay I'll
put on the mask and you take a dirty
mask you know that that doesn't work I
do think that masks help protect each
other if used properly but now I'm in
convinced that in practice there is no
way that it can function because I'll
rely on employees we're walking up to me
telling me that I need to put my mask on
well I'm trying to take a sip for my
sparkling water my huge shots you create
a negative pressure like an exhaust fan
because you've covered your mouth only
and it's on one nostril so it's gone oh
[Applause]
well looking I would even go one step
further it's not that they're afraid
just of their government they're afraid
of their fellow citizens yeah that is a
tariff on a church so the church I got
married terrifying place to be the
church where I got married now there
it's a small little Community Church
they could easily open up on Sundays
you'd be six-foot they could have six
feet apart yeah right
they're not doing that but what they are
trying to do is small groups in people's
houses and it's such a small Church
there's never more than five people yeah
that's actually within the bounds of the
law so this is kind of like we talked
about with the programming how the FCC
used to be an Anthony Kamiya's brilliant
on this he's made this point so I don't
want you to think that everything I'm
saying here is original but the FCC you
used to know the lines and you thought
new media is going to open it up and
instead now we're censored by the mob
like you see with Jimmy Fallon and
blackface it's the same thing happening
here not just the government because now
you could do small groups in someone's
house with five people or less but
there's one busybody on the Board of
Elders at that church who said she's
going to report the pastor if they do it
well I understand when we didn't have
enough info on and people yes that's
what I said guys get rid of this per on
you don't be unequally yoked to that old
bag but I don't even know if she's going
to heaven now 22 about elder is not
being cackling that's very loose great
new international and this person has
this influence and now they're afraid to
open up because people now the mob are
the ones who are pressuring you and I
sit there and I go and I see that Long
Island
lady and you saw that video where she
was chastised for not wearing a mask
yeah I watched that nag oh hold on a
second
we don't know this maybe this mom had
only one masking gave it to her son but
at a certain point how about you just
don't go don't go to the small group
yeah don't go to the grocery store if
every single other person has wear a
mask you know I understand that most
people especially if you have the
sniffles or you have a slight coffee
should wear a mask yourself I understand
it but justice is not delivered from the
mob folks and I know I am NOT I'm not
one of those guys to compare everybody
to Hitler I'm not saying that this is
comparable to or Schwitzer Jews being
gassed but this is something I've often
complained about when we learn about
world war two in school I want you to
stay with me on this context okay Hitler
terrible Holocaust of course six eight
million Jews the number that you guys
give absolutely believe it I think it
was great injustice and of course I'm
glad the United States when Timothy
fought the axis of evil all of those
things Hitler bad zero support but when
we sit and we learn about every other
grave injustice we learned about the
slave trade no I says we learned why we
learned that they were sold from African
slave traders maybe they don't even
teach that now or we learn about the the
war of independence we learn about the
King we learn about taxation without
representation but then we look at World
War Two in a dish go well there was
there were six I don't know that six or
eight nine when I was in school they
taught us eight million Jews died they
said eight million Jews died oh my god
how holistic how do we get there
no they're just they're just there's
evil well I know Hitler's evil I'm not
question that is evil but how did that
happen what leads a society of people to
either support that or passively stand
by while it happens and you never teach
you that yeah because I guess it's just
it's it's dicey tier two but they never
teach you home and what led to that was
at the Treaty of Versailles was it
someone being embarrassed in the world
stage doesn't justify any of it was
notably wrong but when you look at it
you understand the psychology of it
which is wrong which is absolutely
terribly wrong but people were
manipulated I want to be very clear
about that that is that mentality is
absolutely comparable to what is
happening right here there's a local
paper that I read when I'm an upstate
Michigan right where there have been
keep
there is one active case of kovat in the
entire county one one there have been
two new cases not deaths in the last
month I believe but they tell us that
there are 11 in this county no there's
one active case you're trying to add
them all up cumulative ly 10 of them are
no longer active when I when I am there
and I read the local paper it has a
local crime report and there's at least
10 individual little little articles
saying that people called the police to
tell the police about a couple not
socially distancing listen guys that is
reattached oh you didn't get your stop
oh you didn't cuz keep in mind when you
say good call the cops to that mom in
the grocery store I know you think it's
so far removed but ultimately when you
want to call the cops
you want to call a man with a gun
because a mom is in a grocery store with
her child who isn't even sick most
likely and not wearing a mask which the
CDC told us wouldn't be effective anyway
be very clear about what you're doing
you are reporting your fellow Americans
and neighbors to men with guns and you
think that men with guns coming in and
hauling them away is a justifiable
response that absolutely is comparable
to the mentality that led to the
Holocaust I want to be clear about that
have I been clear and I think you know
but it's a fantastic point to make
because in history you look back at
these kinds of things these evil events
these atrocities that happen and you say
how did we get there and it's it's this
this is how you get there right couple
this with a fear of an enemy that you
can't see put everybody and we have to
go and fight this enemy and economic
times
yeah but put hard economic times right
in the middle of it that's how you get
there there's no question that these
things begin very small right the old
adage is you can't throw up frog into
hot water but if you just turn the heat
up and it'll sit there until he boils to
death right and that is how those
situations when you know when you
actually do study the the distance
between World War 1 and World War 2 and
how that culture got to that place how
that how Germany got to that moment you
do see these instances where well we're
just gonna take a little bit of your
rights away well we're just gonna decide
you know tell you what we don't really
need lawyers for these groups of people
you know what we don't need lawyers for
anybody now no really I need courts
right um but you know you know you
definitely don't need guns and you know
what you should do is you should just
move over
here into this ghetto right and like you
know then you should just move into this
train and anyway it's not like you just
walk you down almost at once yeah and
and it is something you tell everybody
else hey let us know what's going on
because it's for your own good
yeah right for your own good it always
starts with like it's an economic
hardship fear and a scapegoat in a
common enemy and by the way the
scapegoat doesn't have to be reasonable
just like the no that's not even a
reasonable we look back we go how does
this compute because we know it's a
totally unreasonable scapegoat well what
do you think is gonna happen when they
look back here and they see that it's a
slightly bad flu season when you take
away the 25 percent of deaths that
actually were never tested or they're
listed as death from kovat when really
it's death with kovat and then you
remove the people by the way who just
died in New York City because of an
absolutely abysmal mind-numbing ly bad
policy that sent sick old people back
into nursing homes like a buzzsaw you
end up with a number that's closer to
fifty thousand which is moderate flu
season my point is people will look back
and go hold on a second you ruined the
economy for that it's not only that but
you know there's a lot of hospitals and
health systems that are having to layoff
significant amount of workers because of
the fact that people are choosing not to
come now I'm not even talking about
electives right setting aside like well
that's not yeah folks who are scared to
go to a hospital or a doctor because of
the fear of infection as opposed to
having an informed way decision a
weighing of the factors about whether
you should go in or not because the
overriding fear is if you don't wear a
mask if you go out in public you are a
terrible person that wants to kill other
people and yourself yeah but in reality
it's not that simple right and I was I
was flagged on Twitter because I respond
to that video with the people yelling if
you haven't seen that video port of them
and bring it up people yelling and
screaming at the mom in the grocery
store and I said that mob these people
are the enemy and that was Pro it's like
was like I got flagged on Twitter is
that how you get to Donald Trump saying
the press right now is acting like the
enemy of Americans is that how you get
to that point where you think that I'm
somehow a fascist what I'm saying is
that people violently threatening by the
way a man there I noticed we're not
talking about sexism a man beating his
chest and threatening a woman and her
child until she has to leave the grocery
store in fear the fact that we are upset
about me saying these people these
people are the enemy and I will say
there's some real value there's some
real value
right now and it's because when I see
people driving in their car with their
masks on and it rolls up I go okay I
know you're a part of that 60% who's
willing to sell out the rest of the 40%
because you're uninformed there is no
way at this point is the date 28th of
May 27th the 27th the 27th of men this
is what we want to do a change my mind
on Cova death totals are over counted
yeah I am so confident in it there is no
way may 27th 2020 to make an argument
for the draconian lockdown measures at
this point unless you are completely
ignorant of the science and data there
is no way to make a scientific or
data-driven argument right now that we
all have to pay for the sins of a New
York Governor there is no reason to buy
we're talking about States how about
Florida Florida not only has major
cities Florida not only was the landing
spot for more New Yorkers and likely any
other state that you can think of right
they all these are the reasons no birds
I mean they used to have some people go
from Quebec they'd go there and they're
drip smugglers and banana hammock and
mullets and people will get breath best
if they don't a beach for the whole
protest article about anti Quebec
sentiment in Florida I get it I don't
even blame you for it but the point is
that big cities they have their the
landing destination for people who are
trying to flee New York and they have a
disproportionate pollination of old
people yeah and they have one of the
lowest death rates in the country how
does that happen and I think what we are
finding right now we're going to hold on
there's no real correlation between
lockdowns and lower deaths or no
lockdowns and higher deaths or vice you
can't necessarily say that lockdowns or
states that have opened up earlier are
doing better but you absolutely cannot
say definitively that lock downs have
worked and I do think we are going to
see and the reason we're seeing such a
discrepancy is because of horrible
actions taken on behalf of local
government I saw people on CNN about
this it's a new new study I don't have
was who said if Donald Trump attacks two
weeks earlier yeah it could have saved
twenty to thirty thousand lives okay
let's play that game what if Governor
Cuomo didn't send people that Hawking
and coughing into the old folks homes
like a like a czars dirty bomb for cryin
out loud what if they didn't do that how
many lives would be saved then you could
probably take off nearly all deaths in
New York we knew we knew beyond any
shadow of a
at this point by the time it had hit our
shores that if it's going to if it's
going to be a pandemic it is going to
disproportionately affect old Pete right
right so we need to protect the most of
all instead they were so busy trying to
quarantine the sick to make sure that
you are scared and you trust the experts
that they ignored what every single if
you were going to polled Americans and
said hey do you think that in New York
they should send sick co-ed patients
back into nursing homes I'd be surprised
you've got a plus or minus 5% on an
answer of 100% no if you liked this
video click one of these other videos
playing in a box subscribe hit the
notification bell you may be wondering
why after this outlandish video this is
such a straight end card that's because
we've recently learned that end cards
actually determine the YouTube algorithm
as it relates to controversy on a
sliding scale so we have a yellow and it
escalates all the way to the word